congratulations also in order for Grey's
Anatomy et was on the scent as they be
thrown er to reach one huge TV milestone
Grey's Anatomy becomes the
longest-running medical drama in the
history of television
okay Wow what that's crazy
take that George Clooney how is Grey's
marketing the TV milestone
they're bringing sexy back for Meredith
Andrew DeLuca and I are dating
I hope it makes you happy thank you et
was on set as they shot tonight's
episode and we asked the cast for some
of their best of gray's moments what was
the most unusual intimate scene I think
I had a romantic scene with TR night one
year we loved each other so much but
just in a different way but I think it
was the chocolate scene being licked off
my body just leave it at me and nurse
Ilana on-call room
Derek walked and honest what is the most
iconic Grey's Anatomy quote that is your
favorite Cristina Yang's line to
Meredith he is not the son you are he's
not the son who doesn't see me feel me
hear me
no that's Specter who that's Pete
Townsend pick me choose me love me so
pick me choose me love me it's a
beautiful day to stay and save lives
it's beautiful day to say fries and your
favorite iconic Grey's Anatomy quote
seriously yeah seriously seriously
seriously you're my person
or when Sandro says somebody's to date
me that's probably the best grazing
outing moment of all time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]